how exactly could the star wars sci-fi
fantasy of obi-wan kenobi find a way to
seemingly offer up a nod to the very
earth-based gritty john wick action
movie franchise
fans are sure it did keep watching
spoilers for the second episode of
obi-wan kenobi and john wick chapter 2
if you haven't seen it are ahead all the
disney plus star wars shows come with
some amount of franchise baggage on the
surface at least obi-wan kenobi is the
most law-laden show of them all after
all it focuses on ewan mcgregor's
titular jedi who's hiding on the desert
planet's tatooine in the years between
revenge of the sith and a new hope yet
the show almost immediately breaks out
this potentially suffocating mould as
obi-wan decides to head off on his own
adventures which reach in some pretty
peculiar directions he won't be able to
help it the jedi will hunt himself
since it's one of the biggest and most
influential franchises in movie history
it's easy to think that other franchises
only reference star wars and not the
other way around hey bill
what
i'm done
however a certain moment in obi-wan
kenobi part 2 makes it easy to believe
that this particular part of the
franchise may have actually paid homage
to a more recent pop culture fixture yes
some fans think that obi-wan kenobi just
dropped a sick john wick reference could
this major star wars disney plus show
really have given a nod of the popular
keanu reeves assassin movie series let's
take a look at the available evidence
the episode features a moment in which
riva an inquisitor eager to apprehend
obi-wan alerts the entire town on the
planet daiju to hunt for the jedi almost
everyone around gets a cool bounty
hologram mass transmission this seems
very close to the excommunicado sequence
in john wick chapter 2 when jon's now
former assassin colleagues learn that
the hunters aren't
john wick
ex-communicator
the apparent reference hasn't gone
unnoticed one fan tweeted john wick
excommunicado moment in part two when
everyone in the city is searching for
obi-wan
another simply said ep 2 john wick meets
obi-wan
there are also fans that feel that the
announcement of the bounty is only one
part of the john wick homage some
suggest that the show's entire vibe is
essentially a big old nod to the keanu
reeves movies one tweeted honestly
obi-wan doing john wick is a real slam
dunk honestly can't believe i'm
surprised that's what they're going for
should have been obvious another managed
to identify the john wick vibes of
obi-wan kenobi before the show even
dropped based on the trailer alone
writing soon after the may 4th trailer
release never knew i needed an obi-wan
kenobi show where he's going to unwick
on people but this show has me excited
these fan observations might actually be
onto something because as it turns out
there actually is a surprising yet very
real connection between the john wick
franchise and obi-wan kenobi joby harold
a writer and executive producer on
obi-wan kenobi also was an executive
producer in john wick chapter 3
parabellum the installment of the john
wick franchise that deals with mr wick's
difficulties after he's declared
ex-communicado variety reported harold's
obi-wan kenobi writer gig in 2020 and he
has certainly been busy he has writer
story or teleplay credits on each of the
show's six episodes harold isn't listed
as a writer for john wick 3 and he's
obviously just one of the many people
who have been working on obi-wan kenobi
still part two strong lone warrior
versus the world energy may not be a
coincidence when you remember that
someone who has worked with the john
wick franchise was involved in the
production you could say that harold is
something of a specialist of the against
all odds genre seeing as he also
executive producer tom cruise sci-fi
flick edge of tomorrow and co-wrote the
screenplay for director zack snyder's
army of the dead it remains to be seen
where the future episodes of obi-wan
kenobi continue to nod toward john wick
or whether the show will veer in a
completely different direction after all
his disney plus predecessor the book of
boba fett had no trouble devoting entire
episodes to the mandalorian who has his
own show perhaps obi-wan intends to
juxtapose obi-wan's lonesome survival
with darth vader's more ruthless and
high-profile missions or maybe it'll
stay on the course part 2 has seemingly
chosen either way fans seem on board for
the action so far
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
star wars are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]